we're going to begin this hour with an
exonerated member of the so-called
Central Park five we all remember this
case was expected to join the New York
City Council after his first run for
office in 1989 Youssef Salam was 15
years old when he was wrongly convicted
along with four black and Latino teenage
boys of the brutal rape of a jogger in
New York City's Central Park in 2002
their convictions were overturned by DNA
evidence and they became known as the
exonerated five Salam served nearly
seven years behind bars for a crime he
did not commit and now two decades after
he was exonerated Mr Salam is declaring
victory in his run for New York City
Council while he waits for the primary
race to be officially called he's a
Criminal Justice Reform Advocate and
works with the Innocence Project we're
happy to say that right now Yusuf salaam
joins us at the table good morning to
you good morning Yusuf salaam my
pleasure the official final count is
today we will know certainly by the end
of the day but it looks very good for
you oh yes and you say oh yes oh yes you
said what has happened in this campaign
has restored your faith in knowing that
you were born for this and this is a
line that got me you said every single
thing that happens to you happens for
you yes what do you mean by that
considering what you have been through
you know it's the reality of being able
to look back and say
man that two by four that hit me
[Music]
allow me to develop to develop
peripheral vision had it not happened I
wouldn't have been aware that the rug
could be pulled out from underneath your
feet that a lot of us are waiting to
live life and God gave us permission to
live life and a lot of us are kind of
playing this double dutch of when do I
jump and when do I jump in the time to
jump in is now
and so
when things happen to you the best thing
that you can do is just say to yourself
this is for me you know this is
developing me this is this is altering
me like right now I get the opportunity
to reflect light in the most darkest
places around the world but had you
always thought about getting into
politics when did this happen for you
you know early on I read the story of
Joseph in the Bible in the Quran and
finding out that this individual was
accused of a crime he didn't commit the
crime was rape and that he went to
prison and he came out and became the
greatest Statesman in Egypt I was
inspired by that story because I was
named after that prophet and so of
course for me I was like
at 15 and 16 is it possible but then it
you know it kind of was swept under the
rug until 2002 when we were found
innocent but there are still people
sitting here today Yousaf you know this
who don't believe that you should be out
of prison that you know the words are
well they certainly must have done
something that night there's still
people who believe that about you
you know you'll you'll always get judged
by the color of your skin and not the
content of your character
and unfortunately in the black and brown
Community when they look at us and they
say to us you're guilty until you're
proven innocent I mean the law says
innocent until proven guilty yes but in
our communities you're seen as guilty
and the system is just going to play
itself out and you'll be able to get all
the time that you're supposed to get and
in our case it was like we didn't do it
right and not only did we do it because
they got stuck with the LIE there was a
young woman who could have been alive
today if the system said you know what
something is wrong with this case let's
let's take a step back and reevaluate
everything but they got stuck with us
being the culprits allowing for the real
criminal to ultimately murder one of his
last victims and speaking of
um the system and being wrongfully
imprisoned
for most people going through a dark
time like that they will come out on the
other end and say you know what I'm
through with the system I'm through with
the police officers I'm through with the
NYPD
that's not the approach you're taking
um you you talk about that two by four
hitting you and allowing you to have
that peripheral vision what is your
vision showing you and what you want to
see in police officers nowadays I got to
tell you I've had so many
um
profoundly impactful experiences with
police officers
and people who want to you're talking
positive it's positive very very
positive righteous actors is what I call
them I met a young girl she was 13 years
old and um
she stood up in an audience and said you
know Yousef I want to become a cop what
advice can you give me I'm a Cadet I
want to become a cop and my first
thought was to tell her to run but then
I realized that I wasn't talking to a
cop
I was talking to a future guardian of
society and I got the opportunity to
give her my best advice telling her that
on the side of police cars throughout
the nation you see the words to Serve
and Protect that in New York City they
go A Step Above and Beyond adding the
words courtesy professionalism and
respect
and so for me it's like if this person
who has found their purpose
can understand that she is a guardian
for society right that's a different
type I want to I want that type of
person to guard me I want that person to
be out there saying you know what I am
to protect and serve all right it's
important Mr slam too an issue that New
Yorkers are dealing with but people in
cities across the country are dealing
with that's gun violence uh here in this
city gun violence has declined somewhat
is going in the right direction at least
the numbers are however the age of the
shooter and the victim seems to be lower
than ever what do you make of that
what I make of that is that we have been
given such a devaluation of life
that if I can't even see the humanity in
you
I was raised as a child to see every
single man as if he could be my father
my brother or my son and every single
woman as if she could be my mother my
sister or my daughter automatically that
level sets the type of respect that I am
supposed to give and therefore be given
and the fact of the matter is that when
we look at what's going on in our
communities when you have poverty and
abject poverty if you will you have this
sense of hopelessness the fact that
people are seeing things like George
Floyd get murdered or Brianna Taylor get
murdered you know in their minds is this
idea that tomorrow is not promised and
so therefore I have to live as
recklessly as possible and in that
recklessness
young people are are exposed to
everything my children I have children
that are as young as seven years old
they see everything you can't Shield
them from the world and in their
response they think that oh this is just
you know to take another person's life
is not it doesn't mean yeah yeah they
don't see that it Alters everything that
ripples into the future of course how we
are as a people yeah which is why we
have to continue to lead the way
absolutely you know my my website that I
lay out my whole platform really kind of
tries to give up people the perspective
of what it's all about and what's the
website harlemforusup.com there it is
right there yes thank you so much we
appreciate you for joining us